oh excuse me
sir you can't smoke out of
here but what are you
doing I I'm vaping what's the difference
the difference is people can't smell
what I'm doing from 10 blocks away all
right well I can see what you're doing
it's called smoking all right so till
you put yours out I'm not putting mine
out how about
that yeah I don't mean to pull rank here
but this is my hotel motel
what it's a motel open courtyard serial
killer can walk right up to my door man
if if this was a hotel he'd have to go
through a Lobby first it's a motel so
why don't you get off your high horse
huh hey good question uh what the [__]
is your problem what's my problem my
problem is I live in a world where a guy
who's smoking is telling me I can't
smoke all right that in a nutshell is my
problem